Pues esa es una capita de la
Constitución que le otorga al gobierno
el derecho realmente o sea
constitucional por ley de pasar una
reforma una ley una iniciativa en el
legislativo sin apoyo sin votación
incluso eh en desacuerdo con el senado y
la asamblea nacional Aparentemente todos
los informes indican que el consejo de
ministros ha decidido convocado por
supuesto por el presidente Emmanuel
macron utilizar ese recurso que ha sido
considerado como de la parte del
gobierno el el de los escenarios no el
peor porque el mejor hubiera sido por
supuesto la aprobación sin ese recurso
pero desde el punto de vista de quienes
se oponen a esta reforma es el peor
escenario posible es decir el gobierno
no confía en el apoyo ni popular porque
no existe ni tampoco en el legislativo
para pasar esta ley y por tanto lo va a
hacer a la fuerza esto Qué significa una
victoria a muy corto plazo para el
gobierno porque finalmente va a
concluirse esta batalla por la reforma
de pensiones en el legislativo pero
pudiera iniciarse o pudiera En todo caso
continuar esa batalla en las calles que
hemos visto con movilizaciones inéditas
en la historia de Francia al menos la
historia reciente
Luis Miguel rápidamente Cuál fue la
reacción de los sindicatos
todavía los sindicatos no han resonado
específicamente a al anuncio de hoy pero
ya este escenario se prevía se preveía
es decir los sindicatos habían alertado
que este era el peor de los escenarios y
que por supuesto van a reaccionar a
ellos incluso hubo un representante
sindical de la confederación general de
trabajadores de bocas de ródano en el
sur de Francia que decía que hasta el
momento todo ha transcurrido en la paz
en la calma estas manifestaciones
completamente cívicas pero que si se
utilizaba ese recurso el cuarenta y
nueve tres pasar por la fuerza esta
reforma pues ocurrirían manifestaciones
pero sin reglas dejando entrever de
alguna forma que pudieran ocurrir
episodios de violencia en las
manifestaciones a venir luego de que se
apruebe esta reforma pensional